mitten in mannheim steht die neue
kunsthalle der stadt vor zwei jahren
wird sie eröffnet doch der schöne neue
kultur tempel ist schon heute ein
sanierungsfall
denn die gesamte fassade des museums
muss wieder demontiert werden
es besteht die gefahr dass sich diese
platten aus faserzement aus der
halterung lösen und herunterfallen dass
das jetzt passiert ist eine sauerei ist
eine riesensauerei ist für mich
geldverschwendung damit geht mir nicht
gut es ist eigentlich eine schande für
die stadt mannheim ich denke das ist
busch am bau also muss gar nicht
wesentlich sein was ist eben schlecht
gemacht das hätte nicht passieren dürfen
ist ganz klar in diesem frühjahr zieht
ein unwetter über die stadt durch den
sturm werden mehrere der 50 kilogramm
schweren platten teilweise aus ihrer
halterung gehoben eine kraft sogar zu
boden
glücklicherweise auf der rückseite des
gebäudes so wird niemand verletzt
ein gutachter wird eingeschaltet dessen
urteil ist katastrophal
sämtliche fassadenelemente weisen
schwachstellen auf und müssen wieder
runter zum schutz der besucher werden
teile des gebäudes aufwendig mit netzen
gesichert der haupteingang wird
vorübergehend verlegt die höhe des
gesamtschadens steht noch nicht fest er
dürfte in die millionen gehen
ich glaube das ist professionell
abgelaufen ist da hat man viele fehler
gemacht fehler passieren ja überall und
das ist jetzt ganz offensichtlich nun
und gott sei dank ist es niemandem was
passiert aber wer ist für den murks am
bau verantwortlich in der städtischen
kunsthalle verweist man auf das laufende
verfahren schriftlich heißt es die
momentane sachlage deutet nicht darauf
hin dass die schäden bereits zum
zeitpunkt der abnahme hätten
festgestellt werden können wegen der
genannten juristischen klärung können
aber noch keine weiteren angaben dazu
gemacht werden
gut 1000 fassadenelemente werden falsch
befestigt und keiner hat's gemerkt
unglaublich
die firma die die platten montiert hat
wird ihn schaden wohl nicht beheben sie
ist inzwischen pleite die mannheimer
einen am ende trifft die steuerzahler
keiner geht die haftung wenn sie jetzt
privat man so was machen dann haben sie
ein riesenproblem
und wenn es öffentliches bau ist dann
ist ein scheint irgendwie keiner mehr
verantwortlich später mal für die
schäden um die zementplatten zu
entfernen muss die kunsthalle demnächst
wohl mit baugerüsten verhüllt werden
kunst am bau auf die man in mannheim
gerne verzichtet hätte